[Musique]
bonjour mademoiselle bonjour
c'est quoi cet endroit c'est notre
nouvelle maison
pas merveilleuse
[Musique]
allô
mon fils me manque tu ferais mieux de
t'y habitué parce que tu ne reverras
plus jamais aucun d'entre nous maman
comment as-tu pu donner mon numéro à
scotch pourquoi je ne tiendrai pas
passer quelques jours avec toi je n'ai
pas besoin d'aide tout se passe à
merveille
il y a un monstre de rire
nous sommes ici parfaitement à l'abri on
est comme deux coq en pâte
je veux rentrer à la maison
allô docteur je me demandais si elle si
je pouvais reprendre mon traitement
l'église Sainte-Marie s'il vous plaît
merci je crois qu'il y a un démon dans
ma maison
[Musique]